Because the nodes are filled in the tree from top to bottom and left to right,
we can number them very naturally as follows.
We'll call this node 0, node 1, node 2, node 3, node 4, and so on.
Because of the regularity with the way that the nodes are numbered,
and the fact that there's always two children until you get down to the bottom
and it kind of trails off.
There's all sorts of relationships that you can figure out between nodes and their parents.
We don't have to explicitly store them we can keep it implicitly
because it can be implicit in the numbering scheme.
I want you to stare at this for a little while and see if you can figure out the numbering scheme.
Imagine we have a much bigger tree with, say, 500 nodes. Somewhere in that tree there is node 72.
What would the right child of node 72 be using this numbering scheme?
I want you to figure out the answer and write it in this box.
But mostly, I want you to figure out the general rule and just apply that rule in the case of 72.